what role has singfield Cup played in
your chess career yeah it's I mean
singfield cup is of course Very known
and very prestigious tournament yeah
it's indeed my first time in you know
classical classical chess and when I was
younger it was definitely you know like
the most Val valuable to play the strong
guys and you know and to win some games
especially in B and Rapid well it's one
of the strongest tournaments in the
world so obviously it's always nice to
be in the tournament I played um only a
couple of times but it's play in a
tournament where I tend to play well so
I always feel happy to to be here again
in 20 2013 it was the first uh time for
me to to come to the Midwest before I've
only been uh you know to California and
I didn't know really what to expect I
don't know somehow we created such a
relationship I think uh with the chess
club from from that first tournament
that I I felt like home here because
here U really I mean the people working
at the club and Rex and everybody
involved in chess are so very friendly I
think this is the Midwest type of
friendliness that I feel comfortable
with my performance in the in the
singfield Cup history has always been up
and down I've been playing since
2015 you know you're playing against the
very best players in the world it's a
very very tough very strong tournament
and it's it's fun to play
I think I played here
for one okay for several times yeah I
know it's very challenging otherwise
yeah it's just tournament when where you
can you can face like arguably strongest
position and one of the most challenging
events every year so normally I'm happy
to to come and play here well it's been
a special tournament for me I've won it
twice that was really quite breakthrough
because I think it was the first Super
tournament I won I've been
playing here since 2014 I think I've
only missed the first edition which was
only four players the way we've been
treated it's also set a standard for
elite chess tournaments in terms of how
to treat uh the players and how to make
a tournament great I have um great
memories here um you know singfield cup
is one of the fixtures in the chess
calendar I I don't think I've won it yet
but I'll I'll give it a shot this time
I'm looking forward to add St Louis to
my small list of interest when I started
chasing it started here to be the first
and the first time 2012 or 13 so I was
following it since I started chess
everybody was playing here and we were
watching by internet and it was really
like motivational for me and I always
learned a lot from here well I think for
me it's rather unique because the first
event that I played in the United States
after a long break from because I grew
up in uh in New York I was born in
Florida and I I started my chess career
in the United States in New York York
and then I moved to Europe so for many
of my formative years I was I was living
and training in Europe and playing in
Europe and then my first event back 2014
my first big event back was the
sinkfield cup so I I hadn't uh come to
the US for a long time I hadn't played
in the US for many many years and then I
came to St Louis and I didn't really
know much I didn't know anything about
the city I didn't know much about the
chess club it was a chess event that was
at the time the strongest in the world
with Magnus Levon they were the first
two players in the world I didn't have
so many expectations but it ended up
being my best event my best performance
I've ever had and so yeah I have like a
special kind of memory of the singfield
cup and since then I've played every
Edition so from 2014 onward uh some
events not as well some events quite
well but I always have very good
emotions being
[Music]
here